Bitte schön.
Guten Tag. Ich heiße Dr. Korkmaz. Ich bin Dienstabender auf dieser Station. Ich würde mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Bin Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja.
Bevor wir über Ihre aktuelle Beschwerden sprechen, möchte ich ganz schnell Ihre persönliche Daten aufnehmen. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Michaela Neuhülfer.
Könnten Sie Ihre Nachname langsam bestewirren?
Neuhülfer schreibt sich N-I-U-H-Ö-F-E-R. Neuhülfer.
Neuhülfer. Eine weibliche Name?
Ja.
Ich bin eine Frau.
Okay.
Braun Neuhülfer. Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 30 Jahre alt.
Und wann sind Sie genau geworden?
Am 15. Februar 1993.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
1,73 m.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
64 kg.
Okay. Frau Neuhülfer. Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ja, ich habe seit circa 2 Tagen Bauchschmerzen, die jetzt immer schlimmer werden.
Und deswegen, die in der letzten Nacht waren die schon so schlimm, dann musste ich heute Morgen in das Krankenhaus gehen, in die Klinik gehen.
Und hoffe, dass Sie mir helfen können.
Okay. Frau Neuhülfer.
Aktuell trauen Sie diese Schmerzen?
Ja, seit 2 Tagen.
Wie könnten Sie auf eine Schmerzskala diese Schmerzen einordnen?
0 kann ich Schmerzen und 10 sehr starke Schmerzen bedeuten.
Ich würde sagen 7.
7. Es ist so viel.
Möchten Sie etwas um Ihre Schmerzmittag?
Oder könnten Sie bis Ende des Erschüchers aushalten?
Ja, danke. Ich habe schon heute Nacht mal eine Paracetamol-Tablette genommen.
Aber sie hat nicht viel geholfen.
Aber ich denke mir, ich kann jetzt noch abwarten.
Okay. Frau Neuhülfer.
Wo genau die Schmerzen?
Ja, die sind so, Anfangs waren sie mehr so um den Bauchnabel herum.
Und jetzt sind sie ein bisschen mehr, schon so ein bisschen mehr rechts im Bauch.
Unten im Bauch und auch ein bisschen im mittleren Bauch.
Das heißt ein bisschen, die Schmerzen wandern, oder?
Ja, sie sind von der Mitte ein bisschen mehr nach rechts gewandert.
Momentan oder seit 2 Tagen strahlen diese Schmerzen irgendwohin aus?
Nein.
Okay. Könnten Sie Ihre Schmerzen beschreiben?
Dummfartig, oligarthig oder stärkend?
Mehr Dumf.
Dummferschmerz, ja.
Okay.
Aber ich kann nicht gut auf den Bauch draufdrücken, dann tut es mir auch sehr weh.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Und Neuhülfer, Frau Neuhülfer, wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Normalerweise ist der Appetit gut.
Aber jetzt seit 2 Tagen habe ich keinen guten Appetit.
Ich habe auch kaum etwas gegessen und mir ist auch übel.
Okay.
Könnten Sie sich üblich?
Ja, ich habe heute Morgen ein bisschen Schüttelfrost gehabt und dann habe ich Temperatur gemessen.
Und da hatte ich im Mund 38, 2, 38, 3.
38, 2.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen übel?
Ja, mir ist übel.
Ich habe es so kurz vor dem Erbrechen, aber erbrochen habe ich noch nicht.
Okay.
Okay, Frau Neuhülfer,
hatten Sie in der letzten Zeit einen Unfall?
Nein.
Keine Unfall?
Okay.
Und haben Sie bemerkt, irgendwelche Ausschlüsse?
Nein, ist mir nicht bekannt.
Okay.
In der letzten Zeit haben Sie ab oder zu genommen?
Nein, mein Gewicht ist unverändert.
Innerhalb der letzten Monate hat sich da nichts geändert.
Okay.
Haben Sie noch etwas beschwerden?
Zum Beispiel Engegefühl oder Wüsten unserer Weiter?
Nein, Wüsten habe ich nicht.
Engegefühl habe ich ja auch nicht.
Okay.
Frau Neuhülfer, ist Ihnen irgendwelche Allergie oder Unverträglichkeit bekannt?
Ich habe ein bisschen Heuchschnupfen.
Da brauche ich dann so einige Wochen im Jahr,
im Frühjahr brauche ich dann auch manchmal Asthma-Spray.
Asthma-Spray, okay.
Aber nur so meist in der Zeit, Ende April bis Anfang Juni.
Und dann brauche ich das aber nicht mehr.
Okay.
Noch etwas Unverträglichkeit, zum Beispiel Wege und Milk, oder?
Nein, da vertrag ich alles.
Sie sind schon jung, aber ich muss wieder zu Wort fragen,
haben Sie eine Erkrankung, zum Beispiel eine Zuckerkrankheit
oder Blutdruck?
Ja, habe ich nicht.
Ich habe eine etwas vergrößerte Schilddrüse mit einem Knoten.
Da bekomme ich jetzt seit drei Jahren ein Schilddrüsen-Medikament
und habe auch regelmäßig kontrolliert, auch wegen dem Knoten.
Und danach habe ich gesagt, eventuell muss das operiert werden,
aber im Augenblick noch nicht.
Okay, misstens Sie die Name von Medikamenten?
Ja, das Medikament heißt Eltyroxin.
Da steht hinter 50.
Da nehme ich eine Tablette morgens.
Okay, noch etwas?
Nein, sonst, ja, ich bin mal operiert worden als Kind am Leistenbruch.
Aber das war alles gut, war alles in Ordnung.
Wie alt waren Sie?
Ich war ungefähr zehn Jahre alt.
Okay.
Und sind Sie vorstellt?
Ja, ich bin vollständig geimpft.
Ich hatte mal eine Fernreise gemacht nach Thailand und Vietnam,
aber das ist schon drei Jahre her.
Und da bin ich vollständig geimpft worden gegen Hepatitis
und alles Mögliche.
Mein Erzsatz im Augenblick habe ich erstmal einen kompletten Impfschutz,
besonders auch für Europa.
Okay, sehr gut.
Ich habe vergessen zu fragen,
haben Sie Probleme bei Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgangen?
Nein, beim Wasserlassen nicht.
Ich hatte mal in früheren Jahren häufiger mal
Hahnwegsinfekt, Blasenentzündungen,
aber das habe ich in den letzten Jahren nicht mehr.
Und Stuhlgangen, ja, seitdem ich die Bauchschmerzen habe,
habe ich jetzt keinen Stuhlgangen mehr gehabt.
Aber sonst habe ich regelmäßig Stuhlgangen.
Wann war der letzte Stuhlgang?
Ja, so vor circa zwei Tagen.
Und wie hat es ausgesiegt?
Der Stuhl, normale Farbe, nicht auffällig.
War bisher immer, habe ich nie Probleme gehabt.
Ich dachte vielleicht, jetzt etwas mit den Bauchschmerzen zu tun,
dass der Stuhlgang jetzt ein bisschen ausgeblieben ist.
Man muss mal beobachten und untersuchen.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Okay.
Frau Neuchöfer, wir sind fertig.
Ich möchte nur über Ihre soziale Lebens- und Familie geschickt werden.
Ich habe einen Stellen.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet, habe aber keine Kinder.
Ich habe vor zwei Monaten aufgehört, die Pille zu nehmen.
Seit zwei Monaten?
Seit zwei Monaten nehmen Sie regelmäßig ein.
Nein, eine Entschuldigung.
Pause.
Was hat Ihre letzte Regelberufe?
Vor circa sechs Wochen.
Ihre Regelperiode ist regelmäßig?
Wie lange dauert es?
Normalerweise ist sie immer regelmäßig.
Ich habe eigentlich nie große Probleme gehabt.
Das war immer in Ordnung.
Wissen Sie, wie viele Tage dauert Ihre Periode?
Was sind das?
Knapp vier Wochen.
Okay.
Besuchen Sie Ihre Frauenarzt regelmäßig?
Ja, ich habe das mit der Frauenärztin auch abgesprochen,
dass ich die Pille pausiere, weil wir Kinderwunsch haben.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Sozialarbeiterin in einer Jugend-Einrichtung für Jugendliche.
Haben Sie Stress bei der Arbeit?
Die Arbeit ist stressig, aber sie gefällt mir.
Die Arbeit gerne.
Und leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Ja, die leben beide noch.
Ich habe eine Frau, die ist 60 Jahre alt,
hat hohen Blutdruck, etwas Asthma,
eine schwere Hüftadrose.
Die Mutter ist 60 Jahre alt,
hat schweres Gelenkräumer.
Aber hat Medikamente und ist einigermaßen damit zufrieden.
Haben Sie eine Schwester?
Ja, ein Bruder.
32 Jahre alt, hat auch etwas Heuschnupfen und etwas Asthma.
Sonst ist er aber gesund.
Entschuldigung.
Ihre Vater leidet an Blutdruck, Hüftadrose.
Und gibt es eine noch?
Aber ich kann nicht Asthma.
Okay, Frau Neuhöfer, ich habe alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder fragen?
Ja, ich frage mich natürlich, was kann das sein?
Was kann ich da im Bauch haben?
Das macht mir Sorgen.
Ja, ich verstehe Sie.
Natürlich, momentan habe ich eine Verdachtdiagnose.
Aber erst mal sicher zu gehen.
Deswegen werde ich ein paar diagnostische Massnahmen durchführen.
Aber ich vermute, haben Sie eine Blittdarmentschuldung.
Aber das ist nicht schilig.
Aber die andere Seite haben Sie Kinderwunsch.
Und ich muss auch sicher zu sein,
ob ich das eine Baby momentan oder nicht.
Deswegen werde ich Blut abnehmen.
Gut, dann können wir das so machen.
Darf ich etwas essen oder trinken?
Nein, Sie müssen keine momentan essen.
Sie müssen nicht nüchtern bleiben.
Bis ihr nach den Ergebnissen warten.
Okay, können wir so machen.
Danke schön.
Haben Kollegen andere Fragen?
Ja, vielleicht habe ich verpasst, aber ich habe nicht gehört,
in welcher Seite hatten Sie leistendruch-Operation?
Rechte Seite, leistendruch war rechts.
Vielen Dank.
Ich habe Frage auch über Ihre Noxalanase.
Ja.
Ja, rauchen Sie?
Nein, ich rauche nicht.
Ich trinke auch kein Alkohol.
Ich mache viel Sport.
Ich möchte auch über die Schädelgülle.
Wie haben Sie vagineule Ausrüstung?
Hatt ich immer mal wieder, aber die Frauenärztin sagt,
es ist nicht schlimm.
Sie hat da Untersuchungen gemacht.
Aber in letzter Zeit nichts Besonderes.
Danke schön.
Frau Neuhüfer, sind Sie aktuell müde?
Ja, etwas müde, weil ich in der letzten Nacht nicht gut geschlafen habe
wegen der Schmerzen.
Und haben Sie auch Gelenkschmerzen?
Nein.
Ist bei Ihnen Sehstörungen?
Nein, ich kann gut sehen.
Ich habe auch keine Brille.
Ich habe keine Sehstörungen.
Haben Sie manchmal in der Mund Schmerzhafte-Läsionen?
Im Mund, wie meinen Sie das?
Also, auf Töse oder Schleimhaut?
Entzündungen in der Schleimhaut?
Genau.
Das hatte ich früher, da wurde mir gesagt,
das war ein Herpesbläschen, aber das habe ich jetzt schon lange nicht mehr.
Bestens 10 Jahre nicht mehr.
Und die vergangenen Zeit haben Sie noch einmal oder schon einmal
eine Weisendurchfall?
Genau, eine Weisendurchfall.
Nein, nein, habe ich nicht.
Okay, danke.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Nein, nicht so richtig schwindelig, aber wir sind eben übel.
Und ich möchte am liebsten, möchte ich liegen bleiben.
Also nicht irgendwie aufstehen und rumgehen,
weil mir auch übel ist.
Und ich habe auch schlecht geschlafen, unser bisschen Fieber.
Also da ist mir nicht gut.
Ich brauche Ruhe.
Bechdet eine Drogenabhängigkeit?
Nein, Drogen habe ich noch nie genommen.
Wie haben Ihre Bauchschmerzen miterzeit verändert?
Am Anfang waren Sie, das habe ich auch schon mal, glaube ich, gesagt,
im Nähe des Bauchnabels in der Mitte.
Und dann haben Sie sich so nach einigen Stunden so ein bisschen mehr
nach rechts verlagert.
Im Laufe der Zeit, die Schlimma geworden.
Wie wieder?
Im Verlauf, die Schlimma geworden.
Die Bauchschmerzen sind schon etwas schlimmer geworden.
Anfang waren Sie vielleicht etwas weniger,
als Sie jetzt zur Zeit.
Ja, das wurde etwas schlimmer.
Ist Ihr schmerzlagerabhängig?
Das habe ich nicht ausprobiert bisher.
Wie gesagt, ich habe jetzt mehr gelegen auf dem Rücken.
Ich habe die Knie etwas angezogen und habe gemerkt,
ich kann nicht Schweres auf dem Bauch haben.
Ich habe das auch nicht auf dem Bauch drücken.
Aber nicht unbedingt lagerabhängig, kann ich nicht sagen.
Ich möchte es weiterfragen.
Am Anfang, die Schmerzen, gehen Winde ab?
Ich glaube schon, da kann ich mich gar nicht mehr so richtig dran erinnern.
Aber ich habe jetzt nicht den Eindruck,
dass ich sehr viel Luft im Bauch habe oder sehr viel Wind im Bauch habe.
Sie haben gesagt, du verschmerzen.
Sind die Schmerzen dauerhaft oder gehen wieder weg?
Ja, dauerhaft.
Sie haben gesagt, ich habe die Hand,
die Schmerzen auf dem Bauch drücken.
Ich habe versucht, mit der Hand auf dem Bauch zu drücken.
Das habe ich dann nicht mehr gemacht.
Könnt ihr mir als erstes ein paar Anfangen?
Ja, ok.
Bitte schön.
Guten Tag. Ich habe einen neuen Patientin.
Ich möchte Ihnen vorstellen, haben Sie dafür, Herr Seitz?
Ja, habe ich.
Michael Neuhöfer, Frau Michael Neuhöfer,
ist 30-jährige Patientin.
Sie kann heute wegen seit zwei Tagen bestehende
rechte Hippogastrik Schmerzen zu uns.
Die Schmerzen haben erst mal in den Bauch-Nabel angefangen.
Danach wandern die rechten Hippogastrik-Bereiche.
Die Schmerzen liegen auf einer Schmerzskala bei Zürich.
Heute hat die Patientin eine Parastomol eingenommen,
aber es war nicht so hilfreich.
Die Schmerzen sind dumpfartig.
Sie hatte keinen Unfall oder bestimmte Auslöser.
Sie hatte Fieber im Mund, 39,2.
38,2.
Sie leidet in Appetenz, dauseher Oxyptopaschen, Insomnia und Schüttoffrost.
Sie hat eine Strom, deswegen nimmt sie regelmäßig
die Erlteroxyn 20 mg morgens.
Außerdem hat sie auch eine Postschulüffel,
die von April bis Juni nimmt,
die Asthma-Spray und sie hat Kinderwunsch,
deswegen seit zwei Monaten nimmt sie keine Pile.
Die letzte Regelbelutung war vor sechs Wochen.
Ist die Patientin voroperiert?
Ja, sie hat zehn Jahre,
sie hat wegen einer unabhängigen Hygienopäne operiert.
Auf welcher Seite war die?
Rechts Seite.
Sie leidet an Arterio Hipertoni, Asthma und Cox Arthrose.
Sie leidet an Rheume, sie hat einen Bruder.
Gibt es bei der Patientin noch persönliche Risikofaktoren?
Ja, sie hat Kinderwunsch und normalerweise dauert
ihre Periode vier Wochen, aber letzte Periode war vor sechs Wochen.
Man muss unbedingt kontrolliert mit besserer HSC.
Raucht die Patientin?
Nein, sie traut nicht.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtdiagnose?
Ja, meine Verdachtdiagnose ist eine Appendicitis.
Als Verdachtdiagnose denke ich eine Ileus- und Zubat-Gravidite.
Ich werde erst einmal eine körperliche Untersuchung,
besonders Kontrolle durchschmerzen und abwehrspannung.
Danach nehme ich Blutab, ich kontrolliere
Entzündungparameter, Blutbild und Beterhes EG.
Danach werde ich eine Ultraschalldruckwurren.
Gut, ich denke diese Differenzial- und Verdachtdiagnose
kann ich nachvollziehen, kann ich teilen.
Wenn man sich die Schmerz-Karakteristik
mit dem leicht wandernen Schmerz nach rechts
hat, muss man in einem Prozess im Bereich Iliozyl-Kal
Appendicitis denken, aber auch bei der Vorgeschichte,
dass die Pille vor zwei Monaten pausiert wurde,
die letzte Periode vor sechs Wochen war,
eine Gravidität, Tugengravidität oder ähnliches denken.
Sicherlich auch ein gynäkologisches Konzil ist sinnvoll.
Gut, von Ihrer Aglarnese her, denke ich,
haben Sie das sehr systematisch und ruhig vorgetragen,
der Patient hingelegen hat gegeben, auch Fragen zu stellen.
Sie haben vergessen, das wurde nachgelegt,
nach Nikotin und Alkohol zu fragen.
Das haben Sie gemerkt, das sollten Sie wirklich nicht vergessen
an den Risikofaktoren.
Versuchen Sie noch mehr medizinische Begriffe,
vielleicht einzufügen, wenn Sie sagen, die Patientin kommt
wegen seit zwei Tagen bestehender Schmerzen.
Anfangs haben Sie gesagt vom Bauchnabel, da sagen Sie ruhig,
seit zwei Tagen bestehender Schmerzen, Anfangs umbilikal,
die dann im Verlauf mehr in den rechten Mittelunterbauch,
und Sie haben dann, glaube ich, gesagt Hypogastrium,
ich würde fast eher sagen Hypochondrium,
Mittelbauch und Unterbauch ziehen.
Also umbilikal würde ich dann sagen, statt Bauchnabel.
Das macht es Ihnen, die anderen Begriffe, Nausea und Insomnie,
finde ich, haben Sie auch gut gemacht.
Bei der Diagnose der Stroma habe ich erwähnt, als Patientin,
dass ich auch einen Knoten habe in der Schildrüse,
der kontrolliert wird.
Da sollten Sie dann sagen, die Patientin wird wegen einer
Stroma Nausea, Medikamentös behandelt,
Stroma Nausea, Medikamentös behandelt mit L-Teroxin 50
und auch kontinuierlich überwacht, was ja bei Knogen
durchaus auch sinnvoll ist.
Ja, aber die anderen Sachen finde ich, Sie haben das,
die Coxatrose erwähnt, beim Vater, die artellelle Hypertorie.
Gut, das entzündliche Gelenkräuber kann man so benennen.
Man kann das vielleicht, aber das habe ich ja auch nicht näher,
haben Sie das auch befragt.
Das war ja auch nicht so entscheidend im Rahmen der Anamneseerhebung.
Ja, ich denke, das haben Sie gut gemacht
und wichtig war, dass Sie auch nicht zu komplizierte Sätze gemacht haben,
was ich immer wichtig finde, weil da bestehen immer das Risiko,
dass man sich in komplizierten Sätzen dann am Ende nicht mehr
wiederfindet.
Was habe ich jetzt alles gesagt und das finde ich, haben Sie sehr gut
gemacht.
Vielen Dank.
Suchen Sie ein paar medizinische Fachbegriffe noch eben mehr
in die Vorstellung beim Oberarzt zu bringen.
Okay, natürlich. Vielen Dank.